er stellt mal eben das gas ab polen und
bulgarien und nicht irgendwann sondern
ganz genau paul ab heute also das ist
große klappe und dann was da hinter der
macht halt sofort was er sagt der putin
erstellt sofort das gas ab was bedeutet
das ist das jetzt daher sehen wir die
pipeline noch mal diese gas pipeline
jamal von gazprom durch die dann eben
nach polen und bulgarien ab heute nichts
mehr fliest putin hat den gashahn
abgedreht ist das ein zeichen von putins
stärke oder ist dass am ende ein zeichen
von zunehmender schwäche paul
stand jetzt ist es ein zeichen von
putins stärke denn die debatten ob
europa diesen schritt zuerst unternehmen
würde oder einzelne länder diesen
schritt unternehmen würde und jetzt
kommt's putin dem zuvor und insbesondere
bei polen eben ja das land
wahrscheinlich mit dem russland mit
anderen in osteuropa am meisten
verfeindet ist
gleichzeitig muss man sich die frage
stellen was bedeutet das jetzt für die
gesamte europäische union
und wenn wladimir putin polen
tatsächlich den gashahn abgedreht weil
so hört man aus dem keller holen eben
nicht bereit war in rubel zu bezahlen
und das war ja die lösung die man
gefunden hat in europa man wollte nicht
in ruh bezahlen sondern in euro und das
ist jetzt die reaktion das bedeutet
natürlich auch dass wir neue debatten
erleben werden was mit uns ist was mit
deutschland ist ob wir denn solidarität
sozusagen mit den polen ganz europa
jetzt sagen müssen schluss mit putins
gab und wir zahlen ja auch nicht in
rubel
wir zahlen auch nicht in rubel deswegen
ist die frage warum wird diese meinen
land jetzt das gas abgedreht zunächst
und anderen nicht also ich glaube das
wird heute die frage sein patrizia wie
deutschland wie vor allem robert habeck
unser wirtschaftsminister dort reagiert
er hat ja gestern angedeutet dass man
schon in den nächsten jahren nahe
zukunft sozusagen nächsten tage nächsten
wochen ab drehen könnte das war auch
erst geplant bis ende des jahres da
wollte man eine lösung finden zusammen
mit polen da gab es einen besuch von
robert habeck polen und über diese frage
möglicherweise ist das auch eine
reaktion darauf also auf robert habeck
initiative zusammen mit den polen zu
sagen wir brauchen jetzt erstmal kein
gas mehr aus kein öl mehr aus russland
das wussten dann direkt
reagiert hat und gesagt hat okay dann
fangen wir jetzt auch mit dem gas an
denn das ist klar es würde deutschland
erheblich härter treffen als ein öl
boykott zum beispiel weil von gas in
russland wie wir alle mittlerweile
wissen sind wir sehr abhängig